mostly streets are a less jolting sight
as America grows used to life in a
pandemic but the economic pain isn't
getting any easier to bear
no one knows which businesses will
return as the latest depressing figures
are just a precursor the worst is yet to
come
menus a history Peter Baine is doing
what he can to prepare for the day he
can reopen his beer hall but he's also
realistic I just feel like we're adrift
in the fog we've no direction we have no
guidance we're just holding on at this
point and trying to see what's going to
open up and get some sort of direction
but right now we've laid off in over 95
percent of our staff there's no
certainty in this whatsoever even if
we're at 50 percent capacity allowed
we're not gonna be able to make any
money and we're just gonna be losing
money and so how long will that go on
for and how long can we sustain that
we're not really sure
the takeaway section he can still
operate is losing money he and countless
others can only wait while the corona
virus continues to ravage the country
and GDP is set to plummet even further
the first quarter saw only two weeks of
shutdown but the impact was strong
enough to erase gains made before that
the second quarter picture looks set to
be the worst since the Great Depression
President trump's reelection pitch is
based on the idea that the economy can
rebound strongly I think I read where
this is one of the best weeks in the
stock market this last short period of
time that we've had in since the 1950s
or 1940s so I think there's a tremendous
feeling of optimism in this country I
can only say that is going to be a
tremendous feeling of optimism I think
the third quarter is transitional it's a
it would were transiting into but it's a
very transitional period I think it's
going to do good but I think the fourth
quarter is going to be fantastic but
economists say these expectations need
to
kept in check so it looks like the worst
and darkest days of this recession will
be worse than the worst or darkest days
in 2008 it also looks like there's more
reasons to be optimistic that the
economy will bounce back a little
quicker than it did in 2008 there's a
growing realization that normal is a
long way off Amanda Walker Sky News
Washington